Alec Baldwin no pudo evitar las lágrimas
al hablar de la muerte accidental de
Jalina Hutchence la directora de
fotografía de la película Rush
estoy sosteniendo la pistola donde ella
me dijo que lo hiciera termina apuntando
justo debajo de su axila fue lo que me
dijeron no sé y entonces solté el
martillo de la pistola y el arma se
disparo solté el martillo de la pistola
y el arma se disparo así que nunca
aprieta el gatillo nunca apuntaría a
nadie con un arma y apretar el gatillo
ese fue el entrenamiento que tuve no
apunta subnormal a alguien y aprietas el
gatillo
la directora de fotografía de 42 años
murió momentos después en el hospital
hay una investigación en curso pero Alec
Baldwin que sostenía el arma de fuego en
el momento del accidente cree que no
puede ser considerado responsable